hello thank you for joining us I'm Henry
to associate director for protein
expression at thermo fisher scientific
I'm excited to welcome you to give
co-expression world our inaugural
protein expression virtual conference
the field of recombinant protein
expression has experienced some exciting
technical developments in the past few
years particularly in mammalian cell
based expression and is becoming an ever
more important research tool as we
strive to deepen our understanding of
protein structure and function and
develop more effective therapies to
improve our lives this new online
conference brings together a community
of protein expression scientists and
industry professionals to share and
discuss the latest advances in protein
expression as a participant in this
event you may access webcast with top
scientists and interact with speakers
during live Q&A sessions we also
encourage you to experience our unique
interactive virtual training lab and
please also visit the virtual exhibit
hall where you can obtain product
information on our latest technologies
for your lab at thermo fisher scientific
we're dedicated to serving science and
contributing research tools to support
your discovery work thank you very much
and please enjoy the conference